Das ist mein Name.
Ja.
Ja, das ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz erstätigt.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegeschiff führen.
Bevor wir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde kommen,
soll ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, natürlich, klar.
Was ist etwas unklar,
fragen Sie gerne nach.
Wie heißen Sie?
Okay, ich heiß Martha Baumgart.
Martha?
Baumgart.
BTH und Baumgart.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachname bestabieren?
Ja, Baum wie B-A-U-M
und G-A-R-T.
Wieder Baumgarten ohne R.
Baumgart.
Baumgart spreche ich richtig aus?
Ja, sprechen Sie richtig aus.
Gut, Frau Baumgart, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 66 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Im 8.02.1959.
59, ja.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin so 1,56.
56?
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuelle Wissen Sie?
Ich wiege so 84 Kilo.
84 Kilo?
Ja, gut.
Das freut mich.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ich habe heute Morgen meine Küche aufgeräumt.
Dann habe ich eine schwere Wasserkiste von einer Ecke in die andere gehoben.
Mit einmal hatte ich solche Schmerzen in der Brust.
Das strahlte dann auch in den Hals rein.
Und in den Arm.
Das war ganz unheimlich.
Das waren auch heftige Schmerzen.
Es hat richtig doll wehltan.
Dann bin ich gleich hierhergekommen.
Sie haben sehr starke Brustschmerzen in den Hals und Arm ausgetragen.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Seit heute Morgen?
Ja, heute Morgen hat es angefangen.
Ich habe es vormittag sauber gemacht.
Dann bin ich gleich hierhergekommen.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Sie haben gesagt, Brustschmerzen.
Es ist so, als ob mir jemand auf der Brust aufhockt.
Ganz heftiger Druck.
Das war ganz gesperrt.
Als ich mich hingesetzt habe und etwas Ruhe gegeben habe,
ist es ein bisschen besser geworden.
Aber ich hatte wirklich auch Angst.
Das hat sich ganz schrecklich angefühlt.
Okay.
Sie haben Druckschmerzen.
Ja.
Haben Sie neben dieser Bescheverde eine Atemnot oder Luftnot Probleme?
Luftnot hatte ich eigentlich nicht.
Aber ich hatte eben diesen Druck.
Das fühlte sich so an,
dass ich jemand ganz feste draufdrückt.
Aber Atemholen konnte ich schon noch weiter.
Okay.
Sie haben keine enge Gefühl.
Keine Luftnot.
Engen Gefühl, doch.
Natürlich Druck.
Aber ich konnte weiter atmen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einem Skalaphone?
Eins bedeuten leite Schmerzen.
Ziem bedeuten unverträgliche Schmerzen.
Das war ein heftiges Schmerzen.
Das war sehr stark.
Also, ja, vielleicht so bei 7 oder 8 oder so in dem Drehen.
Das war richtig schlimm.
Ich habe wirklich auch ein bisschen Angst gehabt.
Ja, das ist sehr stark.
Brauchen Sie eine Schmerzmittel?
Jetzt ist es ja besser geworden.
Als ich mich dann hingesetzt habe, ist es ja besser geworden.
Dann habe ich halt meine Nachbarin angerufen.
Die hat mich mit dem Auto hergebracht.
Nachbarin wurde sie hier angebracht.
Richtig?
Die hat mich hierhergebracht mit dem Auto.
Ja, ich gebe Ihnen eine Schmerzmittel.
Aber so.
Was sind die Schmerzen ja besser?
Vorhin waren die Schmerzen so stark.
Erinnern Sie sich daran,
eine bestimmte Auslöser für diese Schmerzen.
Sie haben übergesprochen,
eine Schwerwasserkissen anhoben.
Schwerkiste?
Mit Spudelschlaschen.
Ich wollte sauber machen in der Küche.
Ich habe sie hochgehoben und weggestellt.
Dann habe ich auf dem Fußboden rumgekrabbelt.
Den hatte ich mit einmal so doll weh getan.
Sie haben gesagt,
die Schmerzen würden sich ein bisschen besser.
Sie haben sich gebessert.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt?
Dann war es wieder gut,
als diese Attacke davor war.
Das war nur in diesem Augenblick,
dass das so heftig war.
Haben Sie eine Schmerzmedikamente eingenommen?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht getraut,
da ich jetzt einen Schmerz mitzunehmen.
Haben Sie etwas angerendet?
Eine kalte Verwendung?
Was ich gemacht habe,
ich hatte das Gefühl,
ich muss das Fenster aufmachen.
Ich habe etwas gegen diesen Druck gemacht.
Ich habe mich so hingesetzt
und die Füße ein bisschen hochgelegt.
Das war ein bisschen besser.
Haben Sie neben diesen Beschwerden
eine Herzrasen, Herzstolpern oder andere Herzprobleme bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe natürlich gespürt,
dass mein Herz klopft.
Auch mehr als sonst,
aber ich hatte das Gefühl,
dass das wie verrückt schneller ist.
Nicht schneller?
Nein, also hatte ich nicht das Gefühl.
Haben Sie noch etwas bemerkt,
unangenehmer neben diesen Beschwerden?
Ja, ich musste so ein bisschen husten,
aber sonst ist mir eigentlich nichts aufgefallen.
Mit Auswurf oder trockenen Husten?
Nein, das war so,
dass ich so trocken gerustet habe.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Fibre
oder Sturfrost bemerkt?
Meinen Sie, ob ich hier so einen Infekt habe oder so,
hatte ich nicht.
Also, fieberig habe ich mich nie gefühlt.
Nicht?
Haben Sie Klos im Hals
oder Schluckbeschwerden bemerkt?
Schluckbeschwerden?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig.
Ja, schwindelig.
Vielleicht war mir da so ein bisschen schwindelig,
aber nicht mehr.
Also, kann ich gar nicht sagen,
ob mittelschwindelig war,
aber besonders ausgebricht war das nicht.
Okay, haben Sie Verdauungsprobleme,
Futurbank oder Wasserlassenprobleme?
Ja, in meinem Alter habe ich schon mal ein bisschen Probleme.
Einmal habe ich oft mal Verstopfung,
dann muss ich solche kleinen Beutelchen nehme ich dann,
wenn ich ein paar Tage nicht auf der Toilette war,
und dann geht es wieder nach.
Und ja, Wasserlassen,
so zweimal in der Nacht muss ich eigentlich schon auf die Toilette gehen.
Also, Beschwerden oder Schmerzen in dem eigentlichen Sinne nicht,
jetzt ist es nur ein bisschen lästig halt.
Ja, haben Sie ein volles Gefühl im Bauch,
obere Bauch oder fühle ich so so?
Nein, so was habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie im letzter Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, leider nicht abgenommen,
aber auch nicht zugenommen.
Haben Sie im letzter Zeit schwolene Beine gemerkt,
oder müssten Sie im letzter Zeit so viele lange Zeit sitzen
oder lange Reise machen?
Also, jetzt als es so warm war,
wenn man da länger unterwegs war,
habe ich schon mal ein bisschen das Gefühl gehabt,
dass die Beine ein bisschen angeschwollen waren,
dass ich, wenn ich lange in der Stadt war oder so.
Aber das kennt man ja eigentlich.
Im Sommer, wenn das so warm ist,
dass dann die Beine so ein bisschen angeschwollen.
Ja.
Frau Baumgart, schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, eigentlich kann ich das nicht sagen.
Also einmal muss ich, wie gesagt, auf die Toilette
und ich bin auch so ein bisschen unruhig in der Nacht.
Also ich kann nicht gut einschlafen.
Und wenn ich dann aufwache,
dann kann ich auch nicht wieder einschlafen.
Also das mit dem Schlafen ist nicht so doll zur Zeit.
Ja. Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Ja, der ist meistens gut.
Ich muss ein bisschen aufpassen.
Ich habe so ein Alterszuckerhalt.
Und ja, der Hausarzt sagt halt,
ich soll mein Gewicht reduzieren
und ich muss die Eid halten.
Aber ja, das fällt mir halt schon schwer.
Okay. Sie haben über Alterszucker gesprochen.
Haben Sie noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Oder seit wann haben Sie Alterszuckerprobleme?
Ja, das hat man vor zehn Jahren festgestellt.
Ja, seitdem nehme ich Metformin regelmäßig.
Und ja, damit ist es eigentlich so ganz gut.
Und ja, was alle haben.
Ich habe ein bisschen hohe Blutfettwerte.
Und ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck.
Und ja, also,
bei dieser Husten, den habe ich eigentlich auch schon ziemlich lange.
Den habe ich jetzt so, ja, bestimmt schon ein paar Monate.
Obwohl es gar nicht jetzt Erkältungszeit ist,
immer muss ich mal so ein bisschen husten.
Ja, und dann hat man vor drei Jahren festgestellt,
da kriegte ich mit einmal so Schmerzen in den Gelenken,
dass ich, dass ich Gicht habe.
Ja, dass ich also ja eben aufpassen muss mit Fleisch essen.
Und seither achte ich ein bisschen auch bei der...
Ihr Großziehen, oder?
Gichtattack, Sie haben über Gichtattack gesprochen.
Großziehen, Gelenk oder?
Ja, in den großen Fußgelenken war das aber auch so ein bisschen
in den Handgelenk, in den Fingerknöcheln.
Sie nehmen regelmäßig mit Formien.
Erinnern Sie sich daran, die Dosis des Medikamenten?
Ich meine, das ist 500.
Dann nehme ich eine morgens und eine abends.
Ja, auch Bluthochdruckbeschwerde.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwärde?
Das hat man so vor zehn Jahren ungefähr festgestellt.
Okay, nehmen Sie Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme Walzatan, das nehme ich morgens.
Wie viele Milligramme erinnern Sie daran?
Ich meine, das heißt Walzatan 160.
160.
Sie haben sehr lange Zeit Husten.
Verstehe ich richtig.
Nehmen Sie gegen Husten ein Medikament oder andere finanzliche Medikamente ein?
Ja, da lutsche ich manchmal so Hustenmormons, damit ich das Gefühl habe,
dass das ein bisschen geschmiert ist, der Hals,
aber Medikamente nehme ich da ein.
Ich nicht, da kommt ja auch irgendwie nix.
Das ist ja so, dass ich immer wieder Husten muss.
Okay, gegen Gift nehmen Sie regelmäßig Allopurnel oder andere Medikamente ein?
Ja, das ich noch nehme, ich weiß gar nicht, wogegen das ist.
Das ist, glaube ich, wenn ich zu viel Magen Säure habe,
wenn nämlich Pantohexal, kann das sein?
Oder ist das auch gegen Gift?
Pantohexal?
Wie viel Milligramm, die Dosis des Medikamentes?
Das weiß ich gar nicht, was da draufsteht.
Das nehme ich auch nicht so oft.
Das nehme ich nur, wenn ich mal tatsächlich so abgut,
das Gefühl habe, dass ich aufstoßen muss.
Aber normal, jetzt heute hatte ich das gar nicht.
Okay, in Bezug auf Medikation nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedart
außer schon genannte Medikamente ein?
Ja, ich nehme morgens aspirin 100, das hat mir mein Hausarzt mal empfohlen.
So als Vorsichtsmaßnahme sozusagen.
Warum hat Ihre Hausarzt diese Medikamente verschrieben?
Weil ich so viele Risikofakts habe.
Ich bin halt zu dick und habe Zucker.
Da hat er gesagt, ich sollte das nehmen.
Okay, sind bei Ihnen eine Allergien oder Unverdrecklichkeit bekannt?
Ja, ich darf tatsächlich keine Penezilien nehmen.
Das geht gar nicht.
Und ich habe auch eine Jodallergie.
Wie reagieren Sie Penezilien oder Jod?
Ja, also mit heftigem Hautausschlag.
Beides.
Beides ja.
wurden Sie schon einmal verliebt?
Ja, mehr einfach.
Einmal habe ich ein neues Kniegelenk bekommen,
weil ich Arthrose habe in dem linken Knie, hatte in dem linken Knie.
Und dann hatte ich eine starke Gebärmuttersenkung.
Und deswegen hat man die Gebärmutter entfernt.
Ja, wann ist es passiert, Gebärmutterentfernung?
Ja, das ist noch nicht so.
Neun Jahre ist das ja.
Neun Jahre, Kniegelenk, Arthrose, Sie haben neue Kniegelenk.
Das war ein Jahr später, also vor acht Jahren.
Acht Jahre.
Ja, mit einem Alter, da wird es mit einmal teuer für die Krankenkaffe.
Könnten Sie mir bitte sagen, ob Sie rauchen?
Jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich habe früher geraucht, ja.
Aber jetzt rauche ich schon seit zehn Jahren überhaupt gar nicht mehr.
Als wenn diese ganzen Erkrankungen aufgetreten sind,
da habe ich gedacht, ich muss mal ein bisschen vorsichtiger leben.
Sie haben sehr gute Entscheidungen getroffen.
Früher, wie viel Zigarette haben Sie geraucht?
Oder wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Oh, ich habe viele Jahre geraucht.
Das waren bestimmt 35 Jahre.
Aber ich habe nie so exzessiv viel geraucht.
Also kein Päckchen am Tag,
vielleicht so 15 Zigaretten am Tag, das war so eigentlich meine Dosis.
Wurden bei Ihnen eine chronische Lumbererkrankung festgestellt?
Nee, das nicht auch noch.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz selten.
Ja, es gibt ja nichts mehr zu feiern.
Also wenn wir mal Geburtstag feiern oder was weiß ich,
wenn die Kinder zu Besuch kommen oder so,
dann trinken wir schon mal zusammen, gelässtchen Sekt oder so.
Aber normal trinke ich eigentlich zu gut viel Alkohol.
Sehr gut.
Ich soll einfach eine Frage stellen, aber das ist eine routine Frage.
Bitte nehmen Sie das persönlich.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Ich?
Nein, also wirklich nicht.
Ja, dann können Sie bitte mir sagen, ob Ihre Eltern noch lieben?
Mein Vater ist hochbetragt, der wohnebt im Pflegeheim.
Der ist total dement, kann überhaupt nicht mehr alleine klarkommen.
Es ist ganz schrecklich.
Und meine Mutter ist gar nicht alt geworden.
Also die hatte Leberkrebs.
Und die ist sehr, sehr früh verstorben.
Also da war die Jünger, als ich jetzt...
Es tut mir sehr leid.
Wie alt ist er, wenn sie verstorben?
Da war sie so 65.
65 Jahre alt. Ja. Es tut mir sehr leid.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ja, eine Schwester habe ich.
Die ist ein bisschen jünger als ich.
Ja, ist sie gesund oder leidet sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, die hatte tatsächlich vor einem Jahr ein Herzinfarkt.
Ja, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verwitwet.
Oh, es tut mir sehr leid.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir waren eine große Familie.
Ich habe vier Kinder, die sind aber natürlich auch schon erwachsen.
Ja, sind Sie gesund?
Sie sind gesund, ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin jetzt Rentnerin.
Ich habe als Schneiderin gearbeitet.
Ja, Frau Baumgart, sind Sie wechseljahr richtig?
Die Gebärmutter ist ja raus, insofern...
Ja, so passiert da nicht mehr viel.
Auch mit Gebärmutter auch Eileiter entfernen, oder?
Nein, die Eierstöcke hat man dringelassen,
aber trotzdem habe ich ja keinen richtigen Zyklus mehr.
Ja, wechseln.
Okay, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen, oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ja, ich möchte natürlich nicht so ein Erlebnis noch mal haben.
Das war ein bisschen gespenstig.
Was war das und was kann ich dagegen tun?
Ich denke, es gibt eine Lungeprobleme.
Aber das ist eine vermutige, nicht genau Diagnose.
Vor der Diagnose sollen ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen.
Zuerst körperliche Untersuchungen, Labor- und Bildgebinde-Verfahren.
Dann können wir über Ihre Diagnose widerschiprieren.
Okay, und wann machen wir die Untersuchungen?
Direkt oder kann ich warten?
Direkt, ja direkt.
Hat jemand noch zusätzliche Fragen aus dem...?
Ja, ich habe.
Sind Ihnen Gräben oder Taubheitsgefühl in den Händen aufgefallen?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Nur eben diese Schmerzen, die so reingezogen haben in den linken Armen.
Aber kein Gräbeln.
Wurde bei Ihnen schon einmal eine Diagnose zerrt?
Noch ein Schwund.
Also das hat noch nie untersucht, würde ich sagen.
Aber ich bin ja eine stabile Person.
Ich denke mal nicht, dass ich noch einen Schwund habe.
Okay, danke.
Sie sagen gescheit, dass wir Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch machen können.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Und haben Sie kurz Zeit.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Okay, gerne.
Wer haben Sie denn gesehen?
Marta Baumberg ist eine 66-Jährige Patientin,
zeitlich persönlich und örtlich orientiert in übergewichtigen Ernährungszustand
und beschwerdebedingte, leicht reduziertem Allgemeinverstand.
Die Patientin stellte sich heute bei uns seit Morgen bestehende, persistierende
Brustschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung im Hals und in den linken Armen vor.
Sie klagten über Engelgefühl im Brust.
Die Schmerz-Interstate wurde mit sieben bis acht von zehn auf
die numerische Skala angegeben. Die Schmerzen seien ruhig und wurden sich in der Ruhe verliehen
und verliehen.
Sie haben eine schwere Wasserkissen.
Darüber hinaus, leider, sie konnten insbesondere trockene Kusten,
keine Aufwurfs, und auf andere.
Auf die Frage nach Luftnot, Atemnot, Entschuldige, Luftnot, Herzrasen,
Herzstolper wurden verneint.
Außerdem auf die Frage nach Fiberschuttefrost wurden verneint.
Die Anamnesi ist auf den Schmerzen genannt und die Obstipation in
Somni und zweimal nicht unaufwändig.
An vor Erkrankungen, leider, sie haben seit zehn Jahren die Medikamentös
mit Formin 500 mg zweimal täglich eingestellt worden.
Darüber hinaus, leider, sie haben Artillerie Hypertony.
Seit zehn Jahren dagegen nehmen sie 100 60 mg einmal morgens.
Seit drei Jahren ist ein Anfall festgestellt und insbesondere Handgelenk.
Und dagegen nehmen sie Pantohexal ein.
Darüber hinaus nehmen sie regelmäßig 100 mg,
ein ihrer Hausarzt hat eine Habe empfohlen wegen ihrer Gewicht und
andere Physikofaktoren.
Auf die Frage nach Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten gab die
Patienten an auf Penicillin und Jod mit Exantem zu reagieren.
Und an Rauchenverhalten berichtete sie seit zehn Jahren nicht raucher zu sein.
Darüber haben sie ungefähr 35 Jahre 15 Zigarette täglich geraucht.
Das bedeutet, das spricht ungefähr 25 Packers.
Sie trinken selten Alkohol, nur im Feiern oder besonderen Anfällen.
An Lässe.
An Lässe, ja.
An Verneid.
An Familienanamese gab der Patient, der Vater des Patienten lebt in Flöheheim.
Und er sei Demenz.
Dement.
Die Mutter der Patientin ist mit 65 Jahren wegen Leberkarzinom verstorben.
Sie haben eine Geschwester, die letztes Jahr Herzinfarkt erlitet habe.
Sie sei verwidert und sie haben vier Kinder.
Sie sind gesund, sie arbeiten, sie haben früher als Schneider gearbeitet.
Sie sei renntnerin.
Entschuldige, ihr habe vergessen, ihre Operation vorgeschickt.
Sie sei vor acht Jahren wegen Kniegelenkartrose operiert worden.
Darüber hinaus war sie wegen Gebärmutter eine Operation durchgeführt.
Was ist die Operation?
Entfernen, Gebärmete.
Hysterektomie.
Hysterektomie, ja richtig.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben deuten am Ehesten auf eine spontan Pynomotorax.
Die Anamnestischen Angaben der Ämbulierungen, die die Ämbulierungen der Ämbulierungen beenden.
Als differenzialen Diagnose kommen die Folgen der Erkrankungen in Betracht.
Anfisem, vielleicht.
Und vielleicht Lungunrebs.
Bitte was?
Ja, vielleicht anstabil Angina, aber sie haben keine Herzprobleme und andere Probleme.
Was machen die Diagnostischen Mitarbeiter?
Zuerst sollen wir körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Als körperliche Untersuchungen sollte die Vitalparameter Messen, Blutdruck und Pulse und ihre Körpertemperatur messen.
Dann sollen wir so schnell wie möglich Labo unterzuchern, durchführen.
Eine Herzentzime, zuerst Blutbild-Entzündungparameter,
dann Herzentzime, CKMB, Troponin T, die Dima,
sollen wir überprüfen, Elektrolyte, Leberwerte und Nierenwerte können wir auch bestimmen.
Und wie geht es weiter? Worauf abhören Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, sollen wir beide Lunge vergleichen,
und ihre Lungenatm-Geräusch abhören.
Und sollen wir auch ihre Herz abhören, Herz-Rhythmus und gibt es andere Herzschlag,
oder andere Probleme?
Was machen Sie allein vom Augenschein, vom Aspekt her?
Worauf achten Sie da bei der Patientin?
Ja, vielleicht Körperposition und Atemstil,
benutzen Sie Ihre Hilfmuskulatur ein.
Ah, okay, ja, ob Sie mit der Rippenatmung zu sagen.
Und ja, wonach gucken Sie noch?
Ja, ich denke aber...
Was ist der Einlagerung?
Beine Udeme würde ich doch gucken, ne?
Ja, Sie haben recht, jedenfalls recht, ich habe gefragt,
Beine Udeme, aber Sie haben, die Beine Udeme wurde verneint.
Manchmal gibt es ein bisschen Beine Udeme,
aber in letzter Zeit keine Beine Udeme beschwerden.
Sie hat gesagt, bei Wärme schon, ne?
Ja, wie du den Bein Udeme überprüfen.
Muss man auch alles damit gucken, wenn man sie inspiziert.
Ja, okay, gut.
Ja, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden,
was bei den Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Ja.
Wollen wir bildkippende Verfahren durchführen?
Zuerst sollen wir eine EKG durchführen
und auch Ekokardiografie,
vielleicht Ihre Halssituation
mit Ekokardiografie,
zumindest in zwei bis drei Übenen Röntgen-Torax
und vielleicht gegebenenfalls brauchen wir eine Brust-City.
Okay, gut.
Ja, dann, wie gesagt, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden
über die Patientin, dann schauen wir,
was tatsächlich dahinter steckt bei den Beschwerden.
Gut.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, Sie vermuten am 1.
ein Lungenproblem.
Ja.
Wie kommen Sie da drauf?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl.
Ja, vielleicht,
das Problem ist besonders,
vielleicht, das Corona-Koronavirus ist sinnvoll.
Ja, genau.
Das ist auch eigentlich die...
Das ist das Corona-Koronavirus,
aber es gibt keine andere Beschwerden, zum Beispiel
Herzstraßen, Herzstolpen,
Schwindel oder andere richtige Probleme.
Schwindel hat sie nicht ganz ausgeschlossen
und ja, sie hat halt nur diesen Druck gemerkt
und hat gemerkt, dass ihr habt klopft,
aber sie hat eben keine...
keine Herzrasen oder so angegeben, ja.
Stabiler Angina, wenn in Ruhe die Schmerzen sich lindert.
Ja, vielleicht stabiler Angina.
Ja, das ist die Geschichte.
Und ja, was mich eigentlich gewundert hat,
auch wenn Ihre Diagnose mit einem Pneumotorach ist,
zum Beispiel, also dass sie ein Lungenproblem hat,
meine ich, bei dem, was die Patienten gestreitet,
müsste man schon auch am Anfang unterbrechen
und Vitalparameter überprüfen.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Das wäre so mein, also ein wichtiger Kritikpunkt.
Sie hat natürlich angegeben, dass sie jetzt keine Schmerzen mehr hat.
Aber das haben Sie eigentlich auch nicht ganz richtig wiedergegeben.
Sie haben ja im Arzt-Artsgespräch gesagt,
Sie stellt sich mit persistierenden Beschwerden vor.
Und nein, Sie hat jetzt keine Beschwerden mehr,
sondern die sind anfassartig aufgetreten
als sie sich hingesetzt hat.
Es ist besser geworden.
Ja, gut, dann haben Sie eigentlich auch nicht gleich
bei der Beschreibung des Grundes für die Vorstellung,
haben Sie nicht gesagt, wie es aufgetreten ist.
Das ist bei körperlicher Anstrengung aufgetreten.
Ja, und ich habe also zweimal das korrigiert.
Sie hat kein Wasserkissen geschleppt, eine Wasserkiste.
Das ist eine Kiste mit einer Getränkekiste, mit Wasserflaschen.
Ja, und wenn man kein Plastik benutzen will,
eine Wasserkiste mit Glasflaschen hat,
dann ist so eine Kiste schon dort nicht schwer.
Ich spreche aus Erfahrung.
Also, eine Wasserkiste, ja, hat die Patientin auch mehrfach gesagt,
also kein Wasserkissen.
Sie hat ihre Küche aufgeräumt, ja,
und hat sauber gemacht und hat sich halt angestrengt.
Und dabei ist diese Attacke da aufgetreten.
Ja, gut.
Ja, wenn sie tatsächlich im Pneu hätte,
dann wäre das eine absolute Notfallindikation.
Ja, den habe ich.
Also, da müsste man natürlich auch relativ schnell mal einen Blick drauf werfen.
Und was wäre denn da die auf der Hand liegende Untersuchung im wahrsten Sinne?
Ja, ja, Knopf, Gold und Meer.
Sie müssen praktisch den Torax auskultieren.
Und gucken, ob die Lunge kollabiert ist.
Ja, gut.
Ja, immer noch finde ich,
dass eine vegetative Anamnese mit Nüktoriverstopfung schlechten schlafen
schon mal nicht unaufhällig ist.
Ja, das ist eine auffällige vegetative Anamnese.
Also, bis auf unaufhällig finde ich zählig, ja.
Wenn die nix hat oder etwas, was ich ein bisschen schlecht schläft,
kann man sagen, gut.
Aber wenn drei Punkte angegeben werden,
meine ich, ist es keine unaufhällige vegetative Anamnese.
Gut.
Dann, was haben wir noch?
Ja, eine kleine sprachliche Geschichte.
Sie hat eine Schwester.
Sie haben gesagt, eine Geschwister.
Die Geschwister ist ein Plural.
Also, geht auch nur in Plural.
Also, sie hat mehrere Geschwister oder sie hat keine Geschwister.
Aber sie hat eine Schwester.
Also, sprachlich, ein kleines Ding.
Ja, und, was ich auch witzig fand,
Rauchverhalten.
Ja, das ist eine Frage, die ich mir nicht sagen will.
Die Frage nach Noxen ergab,
dass sie oder Frage nach den Lebensgewohnheiten.
Und da, ja, auch diese Formulierung,
wenn es um den Drogenkonsum geht, oder Kontakt mit Drogen.
Ich soll diese Frage stellen.
Ja, also, es ist eine Frage,
die ich der Vollständigkeit halber stellen muss.
Ich habe nicht mehr Kontakt zu Drogen.
Aber, ja, gut.
Das ist mir aufgefallen.
Das sagen sie immer, wenn man sie nach ihrem Vorgehen fragt.
Wir sollen das und das machen.
Sagen sie auch, ich untersuche die Patientin zuerst körperlich.
Dabei achte ich insbesondere auf.
Sie sollen das nicht nur machen, sie machen das ja auch.
Dann nehme ich Blut ab und wir bestimmen diese und jene
Parameter im Blut.
Das finde ich sprachlich also ein bisschen konsequenter.
Also, tatsächlich, diese Patientin hier war, war praktisch angemeldet
oder der Fall geschildert als anginapectoris.
Und ja, sicherlich sollte man, sollte man in so einem Fall
unterbrechen und kurzfristig Vitalparameter checken
und vielleicht auch schon mal Troponin abnehmen.
Ja.
Gut, ja, so viel dazu.
Ja, zu M.
Zu M muss ich Ihnen noch eine schöne Geschichte erzählen.
Ich war am Sonnabend hier bei einer offiziellen Veranstaltung in Reine.
Es ging um die bevorstehende Kommunalwahl.
Und es war ein kleines Referat
und ich war ehemaligen Bürgermeisterin
und ich konnte mich überhaupt nicht auf den Inhalt konzentrieren,
weil diese Frau in ihrer Rede, also in jedem Satz wenigstens,
fünfmal M gemacht hat.
Ich konnte mich überhaupt nicht mehr konzentrieren,
weil ich nur noch darauf gehört habe.
Und wir machen das alle, wir machen das alle auch relativ häufig.
Ich selber ertappe mich ja auch immer dabei,
aber bei Ihnen ist es halt auffällig,
dass es eben auch recht häufig ist.
Was mir auch aufgefallen ist,
dass Sie heute relativ oft haben Sie wieder als Aufhänger
für Ihre Fragen hatten.
Ja, das ist nett, wenn Sie damals
zwischendurch etwas anderes machen.
Einmal haben Sie die Patienten mit Namen angesprochen.
Das ist auch immer nett.
Was mir tatsächlich immer gut gefällt bei Ihnen,
dass Sie auf das, was Sie gesagt hat,
in der Regel ganz gut eingehen.
Wenn Sie also gesagt, erwähnt hat, ich habe Diabetes
oder ich habe Alterszucker.
Ja, Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie diesen Alterszucker haben.
Seit wann haben Sie das denn?
Bekommen Sie Medikamente?
Das ist schön, wenn Sie das praktisch aufnehmen,
was die Patientin schon Ihnen gesagt hat.
Gut, so viel dazu für heute.
Wir sehen uns am Bonnersdach.